là on va voir justement si vous êtes
prêt mais on va faire une interview par
amour
cas mais dont la vie est ce que par
amour vous seriez prêt à vous déguiser
en elton john à fond ah ouais est-ce que
par un mot vous seriez prêt à prendre 17
kg
n'ont
apporté des nattes ouais ouais deux
petites nattes blondes ce pas ouais pour
une journée
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prêt à
vous m drogues dures avec léna teintées
jours
a quitté la star ac
oui ah ouais ouais je crois de choses
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prêt à
ce qu'elles commettent quelques
infidélités
ça m'énerve déjà
c'est quand on aime quelqu'un on a envie
que cette personne soit heureuse et -
sexuellement avec moi alors
elle met pas d'accord il est un peu
alors qu mls que par amour vous seriez
prêt à vivre à trois avec son amant
sûr que non sûr que non la cjv à une
possible aller tous les trois dans un
club échangiste non plus
pour actifs pourquoi
away we ll les prêteurs j'ai pas
attendre non non non attention
on peut être juste voyeur
tu me débecte
vous seriez prêt d'une esclave sexuelle
par aman
avec beaucoup de mal mais
j'ai jamais été esclaves sexuelles c'est
à dire quelqu'un
qui cherchait un mec bras
tu là
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu